Did you know that parents rank financial literacy as the number one most difficult life skill to teach? Meet Greenlight, the debit card and money app for families. With Greenlight, you can send money to kids instantly, set up chores, automate allowance, and keep an eye on your kids' spending with real-time notifications. Kids get to earn, save, and spend wisely, and parents can rest easy, knowing their kids are learning about money with guardrails in place. Sign up for Greenlight today at greenlight.com slash odyssey. With Uber Reserve, you can book your Uber ride in advance. 90 days in advance. Perfect for all you forward thinkers and planning gurus. Reserve your Uber ride up to 90 days in advance.
你知道吗？家长们将金融素养列为最难教给孩子的生活技能之首。来认识一下 Greenlight，这是一款专为家庭设计的借记卡和理财应用程序。有了 Greenlight，你可以即时给孩子转账、设置家务清单、自动发放零花钱，并通过实时通知随时关注孩子的消费情况。孩子们可以学会明智地赚钱、储蓄和消费，而家长们也可以放心，因为他们知道孩子是在有保障的情况下学习理财。立即前往 greenlight.com/odyssey 注册 Greenlight。使用 Uber Reserve，你可以提前预订 Uber 行程。最多可提前 90 天。非常适合你们这些深谋远虑的规划达人。最多可提前 90 天预订你的 Uber 行程。
Uber Reserve. See Uber app for details. days in advance. Uber Reserve. See Uber app for details. Hello everyone. Welcome to our second drink for basketball. Angela, you told me that you found a fun scene in our shooting draft for this episode that we never talked about before. I did.
Uber Reserve。详情请见 Uber 应用程序。提前预订。Uber Reserve。详情请见 Uber 应用程序。大家好。欢迎来到我们的第二期《篮球》节目。安吉拉，你告诉我，你在这一集的拍摄草稿中发现了一个我们以前从未谈论过的有趣场景。是的，我发现了。
It's a Pam and Jim scene. So here's the deal. In the episode when Michael goes up to reception and says, Pam, Pam, thank you, ma'am. Yes. And then Dwight quickly approaches to ask him if he can be on the basketball team. Well, this whole moment at front reception was longer and it had one of those cute little
那是一个吉姆和帕姆的场景。事情是这样的。在这一集中，迈克尔走到前台说：“帕姆，帕姆，谢谢你，女士。”是的。然后德怀特迅速走过来问他能不能加入篮球队。其实，前台的这一整段戏更长，而且有一个可爱的小插曲。
flirty Jim and Pam moments. There's a lot of those in the early seasons. There are. Here's how it was written. So this would have happened before Michael gets to work. Okay. Okay. Interior. Okay. Interior office reception.
吉姆和帕姆调情的时刻。在早期剧集中有很多这样的时刻。确实有。剧本是这样写的。这应该发生在迈克尔上班之前。好的。好的。内景。好的。办公室前台内景。
Pam and Jim are listening to the same phone headset, their heads touching. They are smiling, clearly enjoying what they're hearing. Jim, to camera, says, I'm listening to my boss try on pants. Pam says, Michael must have bumped his cell phone last night, so now we have a half an hour message of him at the mall. Jim says, it's fantastic. He glances to make sure Michael's door is closed, then he pokes a button to put it on speaker.
帕姆和吉姆戴着同一个电话耳机，头靠在一起。他们微笑着，显然很享受他们听到的内容。吉姆对着镜头说：“我正在听我老板试穿裤子。”帕姆说：“迈克尔昨晚一定是不小心碰到了手机，所以现在我们有一段他半小时前在商场里的留言。”吉姆说：“太棒了。”他瞥了一眼确认迈克尔的办公室门是关着的，然后按下一个按钮开启了免提。
Everyone hears loud scratching sounds. Jim says, we've heard it four times. It's mostly silence, but every now and then Pam goes shh. And then you hear Michael saying, ugh, do these run small? And the sales lady says, no. And Pam and Jim react smiling. There's some more fussing sounds from the speaker. And then Pam goes, okay, wait, here it comes.
大家都听到了巨大的摩擦声。吉姆说：“我们已经听了四遍了。大部分时间是沉默，但偶尔帕姆会发出‘嘘’的声音。”然后你听到迈克尔说：“呃，这些裤子尺码偏小吗？”售货员说：“不。”帕姆和吉姆笑着做出反应。扬声器里传来更多窸窸窣窣的声音。然后帕姆说：“好了，等等，要来了。”
Michael starts to softly sing to himself. I love uh, uh, uh, uh, abacrumi and fish. Yeah, if I could have one wish, abacrumby and fish. Pam and Jim look at each other with glee. The voicemail system kicks on and says, "'End of message, press one to replay,' and they both lunge to press one." Aw, early Jim and Pam flirty.
迈克尔开始轻声自言自语地唱歌。“我爱，呃，呃，呃，呃，阿伯克隆比和费奇（Abercrombie & Fitch）。是的，如果我能有一个愿望，阿伯克隆比和费奇。”帕姆和吉姆开心地看着对方。语音信箱系统启动并说：“留言结束，按 1 重播。”他们俩都扑过去按 1。噢，早期吉姆和帕姆的调情。
And if you go to the Superfan episode, there is a much smaller version of this that made it in. Pam just says to Michael, nice pants, did you get those at Opera Crumby? Oh. Mm-hmm. And if you watch it, I totally see John trying not to laugh in the background.
如果你去看“超级粉丝”版剧集，里面有一个缩减了很多的版本。帕姆只是对迈克尔说：“裤子不错，是在阿伯克隆比买的吗？”噢。嗯哼。如果你仔细看，我完全能看出约翰在背景里努力憋笑。
Well, I love any time Michael goes shopping or buys jeans or whatever. Any Michael fashion moment. Yes. Last thing I wanted to share is when we break down this episode, you and I get into a discussion about whether Dwight and Angela's relationship had started already.
嗯，我喜欢迈克尔去购物、买牛仔裤或者做任何事的时候。任何迈克尔的时尚时刻。是的。我想分享的最后一件事是，当我们剖析这一集时，你和我讨论了德怀特和安吉拉的关系是否已经开始了。
Yeah. But lady, we didn't include the deleted scenes in this discussion and there are a few extra ones that might prove they actually have not hooked up yet. Okay. For example, Angela had a candy dish on her desk with Tootsie Rolls in it, and Dwight comes over to get some.
是的。但是亲爱的，我们没有把删减片段包含在讨论中，还有一些额外的片段可能证明他们当时确实还没有在一起。好的。例如，安吉拉的桌子上有一个装有图西卷糖（Tootsie Rolls）的糖果盘，德怀特过来拿了一些。
Oh, and also if you watch this, the candy dish, if you zoom in, is the blue cat paperclip holder that I had for the entire series. Oh, but in this instance, you had candy in it, not paper clips. Exactly. I had Tootsie Rolls in it, to be specific. Let's hear the scene.
噢，还有，如果你仔细看这个糖果盘，放大看的话，那是我整个系列中一直用的蓝色猫咪回形针架。噢，但在那个场景里，你里面装的是糖果，而不是回形针。没错。具体来说，我里面装的是图西卷糖。我们来听听那个场景。
Mm. It's good. Mm. They're one per person. Would you like to have a vacation this year? Would you like to have a vacation this year? But I thought. Mm, delicious. That does not sound like someone who is dating someone.
嗯。很好吃。嗯。每人只能拿一个。你今年想去度假吗？你今年想去度假吗？但我以为。嗯，真好吃。这听起来不像是一个正在约会的人会说的话。
No, definitely not. And Angela had even made a sign that says one per person and had stuck it in the dish and he's just ignoring it. The way he was eating that gave me the ick. Ugh, I know, it's pretty gross. And it's Tootsie Rolls too. He was just putting as many as he could in his mouth. And Tootsie Rolls really make you produce a lot of saliva.
不，绝对不是。安吉拉甚至做了一个写着“每人一个”的牌子插在盘子里，而他完全无视了它。他吃东西的样子让我感到恶心。呃，我知道，真的很恶心。而且还是图西卷糖。他只是尽可能多地往嘴里塞。图西卷糖真的会让你分泌很多唾液。
Yeah. Yeah. So my second scene to prove that Angela and Dwight aren't dating yet comes during the basketball game. Dwight sits next to her during a time out and he's wearing that protective mask and this is what Angela says to him. Is that really necessary? I've almost had my nose broken a dozen times. I mean she's repulsed by him. I mean yes. Now I need to know when did she find her attraction to him? When did it turn?
是的。是的。所以我证明安吉拉和德怀特还没开始约会的第二个场景是在篮球比赛期间。德怀特在暂停时坐在她旁边，戴着那个防护面具，这就是安吉拉对他说的。那真的有必要吗？我的鼻子差点被撞断过十几次。我的意思是，她对他感到厌恶。我的意思是，是的。现在我需要知道，她是什么时候开始对他产生吸引力的？是什么时候转变的？
I guess it's good we cut those out. Well, those are some good extra tidbits, Ange. Cassie's got an extra tidbit for us as well. Cassie, since this is the basketball episode and you are our resident basketball expert. Will you please share with us your Office professional basketball player mashup that you did? Yeah, so I was watching this episode, and I was just thinking, like, which Office character is which, like, NBA, WNBA star? And some of them work really well.
我想把那些剪掉是对的。好吧，这些是一些很好的额外花絮，安吉。卡西也为我们准备了一些额外花絮。卡西，既然这是篮球集，而你是我们的常驻篮球专家。你能和我们分享一下你做的《办公室》角色与职业篮球运动员的混搭吗？好的，我在看这一集的时候，就在想，哪个《办公室》角色对应哪位 NBA 或 WNBA 球星？其中一些匹配得非常好。
Oh, yeah? Yeah, so for Dwight, he was the most easy. I have to say he's Nikola Jokic, AKA the Joker. Basically, he's from Serbia. He comes over here. He works really hard. He's been MVP three times in a row. And then he goes home and works on his farm.
噢，是吗？是的，对于德怀特，这是最容易的。我必须说他是尼古拉·约基奇，也就是“小丑”。基本上，他来自塞尔维亚。他来到这里。他工作非常努力。他连续三次获得 MVP。然后他回家并在他的农场工作。
And he raises horses. Oh, my gosh. That's great, Dwight. He doesn't wear a face mask, though. I don't think he's had to wear a face mask yet. Okay. But yeah, he definitely though on the court can do anything and Dwight kind of forces himself
他还养马。噢，天哪。太棒了，德怀特。不过他不戴面具。我觉得他还没到需要戴面具的地步。好的。但确实，他在球场上什么都能做，而德怀特在打篮球时也会强迫自己
to do anything when they're playing basketball. So, you know, pretty similar. For Michael Scott, I can't say he plays like any basketball player. I hope you can't say that. I wouldn't want anyone to be the Michael Scott of their team. He's not good. Exactly.
去做任何事。所以，你知道，非常相似。对于迈克尔·斯科特，我不能说他打球像任何篮球运动员。我希望你不能那样说。我可不想让任何人成为他们团队里的迈克尔·斯科特。他打得不好。没错。
But I think in terms of personality, he's very close to LeBron James. Oh. Yeah. He's kind of like a goofy guy. And I've been watching Starting Five. And he talks about how like he loves to dress up for Halloween and he loves his family and right now this season Bronnie is playing on
但我认为在性格方面，他非常接近勒布朗·詹姆斯。噢。是的。他有点像个滑稽的人。我一直在看《首发五人》（Starting Five）。他谈到他有多喜欢在万圣节打扮，他有多爱他的家人，而且现在这个赛季，布朗尼正和他一起在
the Lakers with him. I know it's father's son. Yeah, I think Michael Scott would have his son or sons play basketball with him. Oh he'd be so excited. I like that. I really hope that goes viral. I hope this podcast is quoted. Cassie Jerkin says, Michael Scott.
湖人队打球。我知道，是父子。是的，我想迈克尔·斯科特会让他儿子或儿子们和他一起打篮球。噢，他会非常兴奋的。我喜欢这个。我真的希望这能火起来。我希望这个播客被引用。卡西·杰金说，迈克尔·斯科特。
The bond trains. It's Michael Scott. Hopefully he'll like that. And then for Jim, I think he's also another Laker, Austin Reeves. And I'm saying this because last year, there was a game where he was playing against the Pistons. And he accidentally landed on some beautiful women
邦德列车。是迈克尔·斯科特。希望他会喜欢。然后对于吉姆，我认为他也是另一位湖人球员，奥斯汀·里夫斯。我这么说是因为去年有一场比赛，他当时在对阵活塞队。他不小心撞到了坐在场边的几位美女，
sitting courtside, and it made him blush. And then the rest of the game, any time he played really well, he would check in with them to see if they were checking him out. And that's exactly how Jim was playing. Yes, very Jim to Pam, right? Yeah, exactly.
这让他脸红了。然后在那场比赛的剩余时间里，每当他打得很好时，他都会看看她们，看她们是否在关注他。这正是吉姆当时的表现。是的，非常像吉姆对帕姆，对吧？是的，完全正确。
So Stanley's dribble is iconic, super memorable. So for him, I think he has very similar handles to James Harden. And I say this with love because I'm a Clippers fan. But James, his handles are kind of all over the place. You don't know what's going to happen, but it ends up most of the time being successful. So I think with Stanley's Dribble,
斯坦利的运球是标志性的，超级令人难忘。所以对他，我认为他的控球和詹姆斯·哈登非常相似。我带着爱说这句话，因为我是快船队的球迷。但是詹姆斯，他的控球有点随心所欲。你不知道会发生什么，但大多数时候结果是成功的。所以我认为对于斯坦利的运球，
everybody's like, what's happening? Cassie, we're gonna get mail. I would love if James Harden comes after me, because I'm a fan. And then notable mentions is, in this episode, two characters are like, Michael disregards as being like, you can't play basketball.
每个人都在想，发生了什么？卡西，我们要收到投诉信了。如果詹姆斯·哈登来找我麻烦，我会很高兴的，因为我是他的粉丝。然后值得一提的是，在这一集中，有两个角色被迈克尔忽视，认为他们“不会打篮球”。
And then it turns out they're probably the best at basketball. Yes. So Phyllis, I have to give a nod to being Caitlin Clark, because in college, Yukon didn't recruit her. So she ended up going to Iowa, and now she's the greatest of all time. And then same thing happened with Kevin or Steph Curry,
结果证明他们可能是篮球打得最好的。是的。所以菲利斯，我必须向她致敬，她就是凯特琳·克拉克，因为在大学时，康涅狄格大学没有招募她。所以她最终去了爱荷华大学，现在她是史上最伟大的球员。然后凯文或斯蒂芬·库里的情况也一样，
where he also was overlooked in college, and now he's the greatest shooter of all time. Also, I mean, Brian's three-point shot. That's incredible. That's like Curry, he can just throw anything up from way out there, and it goes in. And that long take where he keeps hitting it, and it's like nothing but net, there's no cuts.
他在大学时也被忽视了，现在他是史上最伟大的射手。还有，布莱恩的三分球。太不可思议了。就像库里一样，他可以从很远的地方随便投，球就进了。那个他不断投进的长镜头，简直是空心入网，没有任何剪辑。
Yeah. That's incredible. I was so glad they got that on film, and there's even more of it in deleted scenes. Amazing. Well, that was so fun, Cassie. Thank you. I loved that.
是的。太不可思议了。我很高兴他们把它拍了下来，删减片段里还有更多。太棒了。好吧，那太有趣了，卡西。谢谢你。我喜欢这个。
Okay. Well, here is our breakdown of basketball and we have a fantastic Office Lady 6.0 out on Wednesday. Kathy Bates shares with us about her time on the show. What a fun interview. And my Hallmark Christmas movie, Confessions of a Christmas Letter, is now streaming on Hallmark Plus. They even have a free trial so you can watch it over the holidays. Love you guys. We hope you have a great one.
好的。那么，这就是我们对《篮球》一集的剖析，周三我们还有一期精彩的《办公室女士》6.0。凯西·贝茨和我们分享了她在剧组的时光。多么有趣的采访。我的 Hallmark 圣诞电影《圣诞信的忏悔》现在正在 Hallmark Plus 上线。他们甚至有免费试用期，这样你可以在假期期间观看。爱你们。希望你们过得愉快。
See you then. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
到时候见。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。
We're The Office ladies. Oh my god. I'm here with my BFF. We're gonna do this. This is so cool. We are hanging out talking about The Office. Oh my God, I'm here with my BFF. We're going to do this. This is so cool. We are hanging out talking about The Office. Oh my gosh. Is it weird that we're super fans of a show that we were on?
我们是《办公室女士》。噢，天哪。我和我最好的朋友在一起。我们要开始录了。这太酷了。我们在一起聊天，谈论《办公室》。噢，天哪，我和我最好的朋友在一起。我们要开始录了。这太酷了。我们在一起聊天，谈论《办公室》。噢，天哪。我们作为自己出演的节目的超级粉丝，这很奇怪吗？
I don't think so because I think it's really good. It is really good. It really makes me laugh. For real, out loud still it holds up. I know and it's hard to make me laugh. But you know what? We were surrounded. I feel like we were on like the comedy all-star team. We were so lucky. So basically, here's what our podcast is about,
我不这么认为，因为我觉得它真的很好。它确实很好。它真的让我发笑。真的，大声笑出来，它依然经得起时间的考验。我知道，而且很难让我发笑。但你知道吗？我们被包围了。我觉得我们就像是在喜剧全明星队里。我们太幸运了。所以基本上，这就是我们的播客内容，
you guys. We are going to watch an episode of The Office each week. We would love it if you watch them too. And then we're going to talk about things that happened, behind-the-scenes moments, our memories of it. We're going to have guests come on, maybe some fun directors, and maybe some of our writers and our cast members, people that worked in the crew. Now listen, we are probably not the expert be all experts on The Office. We like to think we are, but you guys have watched it like 17 times all the way through. I would lose a trivia contest to any fan.
伙计们。我们每周会看一集《办公室》。如果你们也看的话，我们会很高兴的。然后我们会谈论发生的事情、幕后时刻、我们的记忆。我们会邀请嘉宾，也许是一些有趣的导演，也许是我们的一些编剧和演员，还有剧组工作人员。现在听着，我们可能不是《办公室》的终极专家。我们喜欢认为自己是，但你们已经完整看了 17 遍了。我在任何琐事竞赛中都会输给粉丝。
I mean, I just met someone who said they'd watched The Office 18 times all the way through. I mean, that's pretty amazing. So if you're listening to this and you're like, hey, they didn't bring up the moment that Daryl said this, you can send in questions and anything we don't talk about today, we'd be happy to make a little special side podcast. What do you call that? Let's call it the special sauce. This is the entree, but if you want to send in a question, we'll put it in our special sauce. I like that. Well, available on Stitcher Premium. Jenna, who is the person you want to send in a question, we'll put it in our special sauce, Anna. I like that. Available on Stitcher Premium. Jenna, who is the person you want to sit next to in any high school, chemistry class, college class,
我的意思是，我刚遇到一个人说他已经完整看了 18 遍《办公室》。我的意思是，那太令人惊叹了。所以如果你在听这个，并且想，嘿，她们没提到达里尔说这个的时刻，你可以发送问题，任何我们今天没谈到的，我们很乐意做一个特别的小型播客。你管那个叫什么？我们叫它“特别酱汁”。这是主菜，但如果你想发送问题，我们会把它放进我们的特别酱汁里。我喜欢这个。好吧，在 Stitcher Premium 上提供。珍娜，你想在任何高中化学课、大学课上坐在谁旁边，
she is the note taker. You don't watch Game of Thrones, so you will miss this reference, but I feel like you would be like, Jenna Fischer, first of her name, keeper of the notes of the records. I don't watch Game of Thrones, but I appreciate that. I know, I know, okay. Well, you would be keeper of the notes of the records. I don't watch Game of Thrones, but I appreciate that. I know, I know.
她是那个做笔记的人。你不看《权力的游戏》，所以你会错过这个梗，但我觉得你会像，“珍娜·费舍尔，名字的第一人，笔记记录的守护者。”我不看《权力的游戏》，但我很感激。我知道，我知道，好吧。好吧，你会是笔记记录的守护者。我不看《权力的游戏》，但我很感激。我知道，我知道。
Okay, well you would be keeper of the notes. And she has made some really great notes and we both went back and rewatched. Which episode, Jenna? Today we are discussing the basketball episode. This is season one, episode five. Baboo, baboo! It was written and directed by Greg Daniels. That's right.
好的，好吧，你会是笔记的守护者。她做了一些非常棒的笔记，我们俩都回去重看了。哪一集，珍娜？今天我们要讨论的是《篮球》这一集。这是第一季第五集。巴布，巴布！它是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧和导演的。没错。
Jenna, do you know what time it is? It's time for Fast Facts. Woohoo! Yeah, we've got some Fast Facts on the basketball episode. It's your favorite part. This was Greg Daniels' directorial debut of The Office. Not just any debut of directing. Of all directing.
珍娜，你知道现在几点了吗？是“快讯”时间。呜呼！是的，我们有一些关于《篮球》这一集的快讯。这是你最喜欢的部分。这是格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导《办公室》的处女作。不仅仅是导演的处女作。是所有导演工作的处女作。
So not just of The Office, but his debut debut. Now he told me he had directed actors before for voices on The Simpsons and King of the Hill. He created King of the Hill for anyone who doesn't know that. But this was his first time doing on-camera directing. He would go on to direct 12 more episodes of The Office, but this was the first. Yes, and I remember him showing up
所以不仅仅是《办公室》，而是他真正的处女作。现在他告诉我，他之前在《辛普森一家》和《乡巴佬希尔》中指导过演员配音。他为那些不知道的人创作了《乡巴佬希尔》。但这是他第一次进行现场拍摄导演。他后来又执导了 12 集《办公室》，但这是第一集。是的，我记得他出现时
in his new balanced sneakers, his gray new balanced sneakers, his like khaki pants. Greg always wears anything he got for free. So like his shirt might have said King of the Hill, his baseball hat might have said the Simpsons. Mindy Kaling used to joke that he just wore all his swag all the time. But he showed up so giddy and excited. His enthusiasm and love for this show and this world and characters, it was just so contagious. I just loved it so much. It made me excited. Here's now a little BFF side note for you guys. So Jenna and I, up until this point in the office, we had that partition between us.
穿着他的 New Balance 运动鞋，他的灰色 New Balance 运动鞋，他的卡其裤。格雷格总是穿任何他免费得到的东西。所以他的衬衫可能写着《乡巴佬希尔》，他的棒球帽可能写着《辛普森一家》。敏迪·卡灵过去常开玩笑说他总是穿着他所有的周边。但他出现时非常兴奋。他对这部剧、这个世界和角色的热情和爱，简直太有感染力了。我太喜欢了。这让我很兴奋。现在给你们一个小闺蜜侧记。所以珍娜和我，在《办公室》的这一点之前，我们之间有那个隔板。
We've been speaking over the partition. But now as we film basketball, we were now sitting next to each other on that bench. It was Jenna, me and Phyllis sitting on that bench all day next to each other. For two solid days. And a day of filming is about 12 hours. So 24 solid hours on that bench. And you say, I just kept talking your ear off. You would not stop talking to me. Yes. The reason we are best friends is because Angela would not stop speaking to me. Jenna just finally gave up. You wore me down. I wore you down.
我们之前隔着隔板说话。但现在拍篮球戏时，我们坐在长椅上，挨在一起。那天整整一天，珍娜、我和菲利斯都坐在那张长椅上，挨在一起。整整两天。一天的拍摄大约是12小时。所以我们在那张长椅上坐了整整24小时。你说，我一直在你耳边唠叨。你当时根本停不下来。是的。我们成为好朋友的原因就是因为安吉拉一直跟我说话。珍娜最后终于放弃了。你把我磨得没脾气了。我把你磨得没脾气了。
No, but we told each other our life stories on that bench. We did. 24 hours. It was like the bench of truth. It was the bench of truth. Everything you could possibly want to share. I will never forget. We were leaving one night. We had taped till really late at night. We'd had a long day and it was our day two. So you and I have now talked for... The full 24. Yeah, 24 hours. And it's late at night and we had to walk
不，但我们在那张长椅上互诉了人生故事。确实。24小时。那就像是真理之椅。那是真理之椅。所有你想分享的事情。我永远不会忘记。有一天晚上我们要离开。我们拍到了很晚。那天很漫长，而且是第二天。所以你和我已经聊了……整整24小时。是的，24小时。天已经很晚了，我们得走
from where the warehouse set was back to our trailers. And it was a little bit of a walk and we linked arms, arm and arm. And we started doing the Laverne and Shirley song. Shamil, Shamazal. I remember this. And we were going up and down and we were like, we're gonna do it.
从仓库片场走回我们的拖车。那段路有点长，我们挽着胳膊，手挽着手。我们开始唱《拉文和雪莉》的主题曲。Shamil, Shamazal。我记得这个。我们边走边跳，就像在说，我们要成功了。
Give us a chance. I don't know why we were doing this. Yeah, and I don't know why we were, cause we were goody, we had lost our minds cause we'd been in that warehouse for 24 hours. But unbeknownst to us quietly walking behind us was Steve Carell. And we turned around and realized he'd watched us do
给我们一个机会。我不知道我们为什么这么做。是的，我也不知道为什么，因为我们当时疯了，我们在那个仓库里待了24小时。但我们不知道的是，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔正悄悄走在我们身后。我们转过身，意识到他看着我们表演了
this whole Laverne and Shirley song and dance. And we started laughing because we were embarrassed. And he looked at us and smiled and he said, you guys, no matter what happens with this show, because we were on the chopping block. Always on the chopping block. Always on the chopping block that first season for sure. And he was like, no matter what happens with the show, this is what you guys will have from it. And he pointed at the two of us, this friendship.
整首《拉文和雪莉》的歌舞。我们开始大笑，因为我们很尴尬。他看着我们，微笑着说，伙计们，无论这个节目发生什么，因为我们当时正处于被砍的边缘。总是处于被砍的边缘。第一季肯定总是处于被砍的边缘。他说，无论节目发生什么，这就是你们从中得到的。他指着我们俩，这份友谊。
And I'll never forget it because he was right. And you say, this is the episode, you have a photo, this is the moment we became best friends. I have a photo of us sitting on that bench from this episode framed in my office. Aw, lady. I know. That's so sweet.
我永远不会忘记，因为他是对的。你说，这就是那一集，你有一张照片，这就是我们成为好朋友的时刻。我办公室里挂着一张我们坐在那张长椅上的照片，就是这一集的。噢，亲爱的。我知道。太贴心了。
And I have a sense memory of my butt falling asleep. Oh, my butt fell asleep. So many times. My butt fell asleep and the shoes I was wearing were called SAS, S-A-S, and they're like what, nuns wear? Yeah, but there's an interesting thing I noticed in rewatching this. What? In the very early moments of this episode, you see the boom microphone dip down into frame.
我还有一种身体记忆，就是我的屁股坐麻了。噢，我的屁股坐麻了。好多次。我的屁股坐麻了，我穿的鞋子叫SAS，S-A-S，那是修女穿的鞋吗？是的，但在重温这一集时，我发现了一件有趣的事。什么？在这一集的开头，你可以看到吊杆麦克风垂进了画面里。
Oh, look at you catching a little boom. I did. Now, normally you would never allow this on television. But on our show, this was considered gold. We kept this stuff in. Like you never not used a take that was funny. Just because you saw the boom microphone or anything, any quote unquote mistake that would normally get cut out of another show, we used it.
噢，你看你，抓到了一个小吊杆。我抓到了。通常情况下，电视节目是绝不允许这样的。但在我们的节目里，这被视为珍宝。我们保留了这些东西。就像你永远不会不用一个有趣的镜头。仅仅因为你看到了吊杆麦克风或者任何所谓的错误，这些在其他节目里通常会被剪掉，但我们用了。
Because you want it to feel like the documentary. Like an authentic documentary. This was really important. So I thought that was kind of a cool little thing. That is cool. Our boom operator was named Nick Carbone. Yeah. And one of my favorite things is when sometimes he would get the boom in the shot, we would yell, you got car boned. Car boned. You got car boned. And then we also started making up a song called, boom, shadow, boom, shadow. Listen, young kids, Google it. That is an old song. Angela, I have to share something else about Nick Carbone, our sound guy. So
因为你想让它感觉像纪录片。像一部真实的纪录片。这非常重要。所以我认为那是一个很酷的小细节。那确实很酷。我们的吊杆操作员叫尼克·卡伯恩。是的。我最喜欢的事情之一是，有时当他把吊杆拍进镜头时，我们会大喊，你被卡伯恩了（Car boned）。卡伯恩。你被卡伯恩了。然后我们还开始编了一首歌叫，吊杆，影子，吊杆，影子。听着，年轻人们，去谷歌一下。那是一首老歌。安吉拉，我必须分享关于我们的音响师尼克·卡伯恩的另一件事。所以
Nick Carbone put a microphone on me every day for nine years. Yes, he did. It's a very intimate thing to Mike, an actor. Oftentimes, you know, I was in that pencil skirt. And if I was standing up, we would sometimes have to put a leg wrap around my upper thigh to hide the microphone pack and then very delicately weave a microphone wire through underneath my bra, up my blouse. And Nick Carbone was the person who did this every day. For me too, for me too, every day. So a very intimate relationship you form with the person who mics you every day. Here's something that would happen though.
尼克·卡伯恩九年来每天都给我戴麦克风。是的，他确实。给演员戴麦克风是一件非常私密的事情。通常，你知道，我穿着那条铅笔裙。如果我站着，我们有时得在大腿上缠上腿带，把麦克风包藏起来，然后非常小心地把麦克风线从胸罩下面穿过，一直穿到衬衫里。尼克·卡伯恩就是每天做这件事的人。我也是，我也是，每天。所以你和每天给你戴麦克风的人会建立一种非常亲密的关系。不过，这里发生过一件事。
Those leg wraps, they closed via Velcro. Yes. They were a Velcro leg wrap and Pam wore pantyhose and I would get a run in my pantyhose. And I would have to change my pantyhose four to five times a day. The wardrobe people, they would put four or five packs of pantyhose in my trailer because they knew that inevitably I would get a run from this
那些腿带是用魔术贴固定的。是的。它们是魔术贴腿带，帕姆穿的是连裤袜，我的连裤袜经常会勾丝。我一天得换四到五次连裤袜。服装组的人会在我的拖车里放四五包连裤袜，因为他们知道我不可避免地会被这个
Velcro, which was also itchy and uncomfortable. It was uncomfortable. Do you know what Nick did for me? I do know what he did for you, but you tell them. Okay, here's what he did. He came up with a special leg wrap invention. Yes. Where he created a leg wrap that used bra hooks. It was like a bra. It was like a bra hook. A bra strap.
魔术贴勾丝，而且它还很痒，很不舒服。确实很不舒服。你知道尼克为我做了什么吗？我知道他为你做了什么，但你告诉大家吧。好吧，他是这么做的。他发明了一种特殊的腿带发明。是的。他创造了一种用胸罩挂钩的腿带。就像胸罩一样。就像胸罩挂钩。胸罩带。
Yeah, like a bra strap closure so that when he hooked it onto my leg, my pantyhose wouldn't run and I wouldn't have to change my pantyhose so often. And it worked. It was brilliant. Here's the other thing he did. He knew that I like to really go for it at the holidays. I mean, I like to eat the pies and the many turkeys and all of the stuffing. You love some holiday eating. I love the holiday eating. And I would often come back from the holidays, a good full size larger than when I left. So Nick Carbone put like a bra, there were three different settings. For if it was post holidays, pre holidays,
是的，就像胸罩带扣，这样当他把它钩在我的腿上时，我的连裤袜就不会勾丝，我也不用那么频繁地换连裤袜了。而且它奏效了。太天才了。他还做了另一件事。他知道我喜欢在假期里大吃特吃。我是说，我喜欢吃馅饼、火鸡和所有的填料。你很喜欢假期美食。我喜欢假期美食。我经常在假期回来后，比离开时整整大了一个码。所以尼克·卡伯恩做了一个像胸罩一样的带子，有三个不同的档位。如果是假期后、假期前，
maybe I was working out real hard for a movie role so that it always fit me. Cause that was the purpose of the Velcro was that you could kind of Velcro it anywhere. So he made this adjustable leg wrap for me. And we called it the Jenna. And he kept it in my kit. It was so cool.
或者我为了电影角色在努力健身，这样它总是很合身。因为魔术贴的目的就是你可以把它贴在任何地方。所以他为我做了这个可调节的腿带。我们叫它“珍娜”。他把它放在我的工具包里。太酷了。
And then you know what? What? After the office was over a couple years later, I got a job on an ABC show called splitting up together. And when I walked on the set for the first day, they introduced me to the sound team, and it was Nick. And I am tearing up just thinking about it. There he was again.
然后你知道吗？什么？《办公室》结束后几年，我在ABC的一部叫《分居在一起》的剧里找到了一份工作。当我第一天走进片场时，他们把我介绍给音响团队，那是尼克。想到这里我就要流泪了。他又在那里了。
So the only person who has really ever mic'd me for television is Nick Carbone, and he had saved my special leg wrap. That is so sweet. I just love them so much. I love them too. We've totally become family and I just loved our crew. I just loved our crew so much.
所以，真正为我戴过电视麦克风的只有尼克·卡伯恩，而且他保留了我的特殊腿带。太贴心了。我真的很爱他们。我也很爱他们。我们完全成了家人，我真的很爱我们的剧组。我太爱我们的剧组了。
We should have our crew. We need to have guests on. We need to have our crew come visit. Yeah, we need to have them come in. We need to do like a crew episode. I would love that. Yeah. This is completely not related to Nick Carbone,
我们应该请我们的剧组。我们需要请嘉宾。我们需要让我们的剧组来做客。是的，我们需要让他们过来。我们需要做一期剧组特辑。我会很喜欢的。是的。这和尼克·卡伯恩完全没关系，
but I have to share it. Jenna wore pantyhose every day. They were in her trailer. The same pantyhose were in my trailer. They were put in my trailer every day starting day one. I never put them on. I, I never, I refuse to wear my mind. I refuse to wear pantyhose and Jenna one day. I mean, it was years. I remember the day it was years into into filming. Seasons upon seasons. And she looked over at me one day,
但我必须分享一下。珍娜每天都穿连裤袜。它们在她的拖车里。同样的连裤袜也在我的拖车里。从第一天开始，它们每天都被放在我的拖车里。我从来没穿过。我，我从来没穿过，我拒绝穿我的。我拒绝穿连裤袜，有一天珍娜。我是说，那是几年后了。我记得那一天，那是拍摄几年后。一季又一季。她有一天看着我，
and she was like, you don't have on pantyhose. I was like, oh yeah, they put them in my trailer. I don't wear those things. I'm not wearing pantyhose. And she was like, what the hell? I've been wearing pantyhose for years. I am such a rule follower that it never occurred to me that I could go rogue and just not wear the pantyhose.
她说，你没穿连裤袜。我说，噢，是的，他们把它们放在我的拖车里。我不穿那些东西。我才不穿连裤袜。她说，搞什么鬼？我穿连裤袜穿了好几年了。我是一个如此遵守规则的人，以至于我从来没想过我可以“叛逆”一下，直接不穿连裤袜。
No one said anything. I didn't put them on. No one said anything. I mean, listen, there were times when I didn't dress the bottom half of my body. Well, you need to explain that because it sounds... Oh, yeah. I should let me expand on that. You are like, you know, commando. So sometimes if I was only seated behind the reception desk, I only dressed the top half of Pam and the bottom half was
没人说什么。我没穿。没人说什么。我是说，听着，有时候我甚至不穿下半身的衣服。好吧，你需要解释一下，因为这听起来……噢，是的。我应该展开说说。你就像是，你知道，真空上阵。所以有时候如果我只是坐在接待台后面，我只穿帕姆的上半身，下半身是
Uggs and sweatpants. So I did get a break from the pantyhose, but I never wore them ever. I can't believe that. I just kept shoving them aside. I shoved them aside for like two years and then they just gave up and stopped putting them in my trailer. I used to look so forward to our quote unquote winter episodes because they would give me tights, which were way more comfortable than pantyhose. And then after a while I had to say, stop putting control top pantyhose in my trailer. I don't want to wear control top pantyhose for 12 hours a day. You and my grandmother, especially after the holidays. This is a sentence that could like set up so many conversations for me with Jenna. But Jenna, you and my grandmother
雪地靴和运动裤。所以我确实从连裤袜中解脱了，但我从来没穿过。我真不敢相信。我只是不停地把它们推到一边。我把它们推到一边大概两年，然后他们就放弃了，不再把它们放在我的拖车里了。我以前非常期待我们的所谓“冬季剧集”，因为他们会给我紧身裤，那比连裤袜舒服多了。后来我不得不说，别再把控制型连裤袜放在我的拖车里了。我不想一天12小时穿着控制型连裤袜。你和我祖母，特别是在假期之后。这是一句可以引发我和珍娜很多对话的话。但是珍娜，你和我祖母
were the only two people I knew for a period of time that wore pantyhose every day. My grandmother wore pantyhose every day of her life. She was like, she always had on pantyhose. I can't wait to be 75 because I think I'll finally make sense. You're already there. I've been a 75 year old woman since I was born. Should we give a synopsis of the episode? I know you want to Jenna. I wrote it down. Do it lady. I wrote down a synopsis.
在一段时间内是我认识的仅有的两个每天穿连裤袜的人。我祖母一生中每天都穿连裤袜。她就像，她总是穿着连裤袜。我迫不及待想活到75岁，因为我觉得那时我终于能想通了。你已经到了。我从出生起就是个75岁的老太太。我们要不要给这一集写个梗概？我知道你想写，珍娜。我写下来了。写吧，亲爱的。我写了一个梗概。
She did y'all. She typed it out. It is. I'm going to read it. Okay. In this episode, Michael challenges the guys in the warehouse to a basketball game against the upstairs sales staff. The warehouse workers led by Darryl want to make it a friendly game, but Michael insists there be a prize for the winner or more accurately
她真的写了。她打出来了。是这样的。我要读一下。好的。在这一集中，迈克尔向仓库里的伙计们发起了一场篮球赛，对手是楼上的销售人员。由达里尔领导的仓库员工想进行一场友谊赛，但迈克尔坚持获胜者必须有奖品，或者更准确地说，
a punishment for the losers. Michael suggests the losers have to work on Saturday and then he taunts Darryl with chicken sounds until Darryl agrees. Correct. But things will get more interesting in this episode. That's not where it ends, Angela. I know. The drama does not end there. There's another dun dun dun Angela. I know you drama does not end there another done done done paragraph We got here more interesting because Pam's fiance Roy works in the warehouse. Oh snap Yes, so we find out that she is caught between her office crushed gym. Mm-hmm and her actual fiance Roy, who's she gonna root for upstairs or downstairs? I don't know. Let's start at the beginning Michael enters the office and starts asking if people are ready for the big game.
失败者要受罚。迈克尔建议失败者周六必须加班，然后他用鸡叫声嘲讽达里尔，直到达里尔同意。没错。但这一集的事情会变得更有趣。安吉拉，还没结束呢。我知道。戏剧性并没有就此结束。还有另一个，当当当，安吉拉。我知道戏剧性并没有就此结束，还有另一个当当当段落。我们这里有，更有趣的是，因为帕姆的未婚夫罗伊在仓库工作。噢，天哪。是的，所以我们发现她夹在办公室暗恋对象吉姆和她真正的未婚夫罗伊之间。她会支持谁？楼上还是楼下？我不知道。让我们从头开始。迈克尔走进办公室，开始问大家是否准备好迎接这场大战了。
Oh, this is early days of the office. Michael was super cringy. He was. Oh my God. He was so, like, first of all, he like just accosts you. He just walks up and swats you with a newspaper. He's like, bam, whack. He does.
噢，这是《办公室》的早期。迈克尔超级尴尬。他确实是。天哪。他太，首先，他直接冲过来，用报纸拍你。他说，砰，啪。他确实。
Yeah. He would come up to my desk and I would flinch. Yeah. With Uber Reserve, good things come to those who plan ahead. Family vacay? Reserve your ride as soon as you book your flights. To all the planners, now you can reserve your Uber ride up to 90 days in advance. See Uber app for details. Okay. Let's talk about the game down in the warehouse.
是的。他会走到我的桌子前，我会畏缩。是的。有了Uber Reserve，提前计划的人会有好运。家庭度假？预订航班后立即预订行程。对于所有的规划者，现在您可以提前90天预订Uber行程。详情请查看Uber应用程序。好的。我们来谈谈仓库里的比赛。
I'm going to say- Oh, you have to talk about the Todd Packer moment. Okay. One of my absolute favorite moments. First, I want to say that I went back and watched the entire first season of The Office, and it is my personal opinion that basketball is one of the best episodes we ever did. Really? I absolutely love it.
我要说——噢，你必须谈谈托德·帕克的那一刻。好的。我最喜欢的时刻之一。首先，我想说我回去看了《办公室》的第一季全集，我个人认为《篮球》是我们拍过的最好的一集之一。真的吗？我非常喜欢。
I think it is so good. One of my favorite scenes in this episode is the one where Dwight follows Michael into his office and tries to convince him that he should be part of the basketball team. And they get in this exchange that is so wonderful. Michael says, no, not after what happened at that pickup game. And then Dwight is like, I, I apologize for that. And he's like, I vouched for you. I vouched for you in front of Todd Packer. Now here's the amazing thing about this show is that we've never met Todd Packer. He's only been mentioned one other time, which is in the pilot, when he calls in on speakerphone while Michael's having a meeting with Jan.
我觉得它太棒了。这一集中我最喜欢的场景之一是德怀特跟着迈克尔走进办公室，试图说服他让自己加入篮球队。他们进行了这段非常精彩的对话。迈克尔说，不，在那场野球赛之后就不行了。然后德怀特说，我，我为此道歉。他说，我为你担保。我在托德·帕克面前为你担保。现在关于这部剧最神奇的事情是，我们从未见过托德·帕克。他只在试播集中被提到过一次，当时迈克尔和简开会时，他打来了免提电话。
He says a bunch of inappropriate stuff, and Michael just shuts him off the speakerphone. But you can tell in that phone call, Michael covets this guy. Loves this man. He's the coolest guy. We are not going to meet Todd Packer. I looked it up.
他说了一堆不恰当的话，迈克尔直接挂断了免提。但你可以从那个电话中看出，迈克尔很羡慕这个家伙。很爱这个人。他是最酷的家伙。我们不会见到托德·帕克。我查过了。
Do you know when we finally meet him? Uh, season... Season two. Two? Sexual harassment episode. Oh, that's perfect. Which, yes, I know. I looked it up. Do you know when we finally meet him? Season. Season two. Sexual harassment episode. Oh, that's perfect. Which, yes, I know. But that's like far.
你知道我们什么时候最终见到他吗？呃，第二季……第二季？性骚扰那一集。噢，那太完美了。是的，我知道。我查过了。你知道我们什么时候最终见到他吗？第二季。性骚扰那一集。噢，那太完美了。是的，我知道。但那还很远。
Yeah. Like that's a while. Well, I do love this. And I feel like Greg Daniels was so great about this. And with our writer's room is we just jumped in the middle of these people's lives. You know, we don't tell backstory and the audience just has to catch up.
是的，那还要很久。好吧，我确实很喜欢这一点。我觉得格雷格·丹尼尔斯在这方面做得很好，我们的编剧室也是，我们只是跳进了这些人生活的中间。你知道，我们不讲背景故事，观众必须自己跟上。
And I love that. Yeah. I love all these little little nuggets and this episode in particular has a lot of little nuggets You see these dynamics that then play out years later I love and I don't want to jump too far ahead but like Dwight and Angela's power struggle It's the first time you see it in this episode. All right, so we'll play that clip. I think I should be on the team. No And that's not me being mean Dwight that is based on your past behavior Alright, so we'll play that clip. I think I should be on the team. No. And that's not me being mean, Dwight. That is based on your past behavior. Oh, please. When I let him come to my pickup game...
我喜欢这一点。是的。我喜欢所有这些小细节，这一集特别有很多小细节。你看到了这些后来几年才展现出来的动态。我喜欢，我不想跳得太远，但比如德怀特和安吉拉的权力斗争，这是你第一次在这一集中看到它。好吧，我们来播放那个片段。我觉得我应该进队。不。那不是我刻薄，德怀特，那是基于你过去的表现。好吧，我们来播放那个片段。我觉得我应该进队。不。那不是我刻薄，德怀特。那是基于你过去的表现。噢，拜托。当我让他参加我的野球赛时……
I apologize for that. I vouch for you. I vouch for you in front of Todd Packer, Dwight! Alright, here's what I'm gonna do. The hand strikes and gives a flower. You are not going to play basketball. No. But I need somebody to come in and take over the holiday and weekend work calendar. I can handle that.
我为此道歉。我为你担保。我在托德·帕克面前为你担保，德怀特！好吧，我要这么做。手一挥，送上一朵花。你不能打篮球。不。但我需要有人进来接管假期和周末的工作日程。我可以处理。
Good. Excellent. It'll be fun. Because corporate wants somebody to be here on Saturday, and so we're gonna have to have a couple people come in on the weekends, and I know nobody's gonna want to do it, and everybody's gonna complain and bitch, and I don't want to have to deal with that. And that's why you have an assistant regional manager. Yes, it is. Assistant to the regional manager. Same thing.
好。太棒了。那会很有趣。因为公司希望有人周六在这里，所以我们得让几个人周末过来，我知道没人想做，每个人都会抱怨和发牢骚，我不想处理这些。这就是为什么你有助理区域经理。是的，是助理区域经理。助理到区域经理。是一回事。
No, it's not. It's lower. It's close. I love everything about Steve. I know so much. Steve, he's so brilliant. And everyone's going to bitch and complain. He just hates, he does not want to be the bad guy. No.
不，不是。那是更低一级。差不多。我喜欢史蒂夫的一切。我知道太多了。史蒂夫，他太天才了。每个人都会发牢骚和抱怨。他只是讨厌，他不想做坏人。不。
Desperately doesn't want to be the bad guy. He wants to be liked and that really is at the heart of this show for Michael is his, this office is his family. He wants them so badly to love him. I love in this little scene when Rain looks to the camera. He has a few looks to the camera that are just great. And I feel like this was really fun for all of us, this documentary kind of genre, because we did get to do that.
他非常不想做坏人。他想被喜欢，这确实是迈克尔这个角色的核心，这个办公室就是他的家。他非常渴望他们爱他。我喜欢这个小场景里雷恩看向镜头的时候。他有几次看向镜头的眼神都很棒。我觉得这对我们所有人来说都很有趣，这种纪录片式的类型，因为我们确实做到了。
And even in years later, I have jobs and every once in a while a director would say, Angela, you just looked at camera. You can't look at camera. I do it still too. I'm like, oh crap, sorry, I for nine years, I would check in with the camera. It's so true. The camera was a character. Yeah, it was another person that we could relate to the documentarian quote unquote. Right. And so we were encouraged to make them a part of the conversation. Yeah, I know. And then it's weird to then take other jobs where you're like,
甚至在几年后，我有工作时，偶尔会有导演说，安吉拉，你刚才看向镜头了。你不能看镜头。我到现在还会这样。我说，噢该死，抱歉，九年来，我习惯了和镜头互动。太真实了。镜头是一个角色。是的，它是我们可以与之互动的另一个人，所谓的纪录片制作者。对。所以我们被鼓励让他们成为对话的一部分。是的，我知道。然后去接其他工作时会觉得很奇怪，你会觉得，
oh, right, right, you're not actually filming me. Or back to pretending like this is not, you're not in the room. Exactly, exactly. Another great scene is when Michael leads Ryan down into the warehouse. There's that great quote, he's managing by walking around. Oh, yes. That would be in his book, How I Manage, Michael Scott's book, How I Manage.
噢，对了，对了，你并没有真的在拍我。或者回到假装这不是，你不在房间里。没错，没错。另一个很棒的场景是迈克尔带着瑞恩走进仓库。那句名言，他在“走动式管理”。噢，是的。那会出现在他的书里，《我如何管理》，迈克尔·斯科特的书，《我如何管理》。
Here's a little trivia. Yeah, do it. The first time we go down into the warehouse. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I take that back. We go down into the warehouse in the episode before this called The Alliance, but this is the first time we go down and get introduced to the warehouse staff.
这里有个小花絮。好的，说吧。我们第一次下到仓库。对。对。好吧，我收回前言。我们在上一集《联盟》中就下过仓库，但这是我们第一次下楼并被介绍给仓库员工认识。
Yes, that's right. And Michael and Ryan go down these stairs. Now, in this episode, we were filming in Culver City. So those stairs actually were real. They actually existed. We filmed in an actual building that was an old company. Yeah. And so...
是的，没错。迈克尔和瑞安走下了楼梯。当时我们在卡尔弗城拍摄。所以那些楼梯是真实的。它们确实存在。我们在一家旧公司的真实建筑里拍摄。是的。所以……
These offices were on the second floor of that building too. That's right. And so you go down the stairs to the warehouse, but in years later they recreated the whole office in a different location on a soundstage. And those stairs still existed, but they led nowhere. That was a tiny, tiny closet about three feet wide, and you would hide in the tiny closet, and then on cue you would open the door and walk out. So there were many times when you would either be up there by yourself in the tiny closet or you'd be up there, like one time I was up there with Oscar and Brian as Kevin, and there's not a lot of space up there.
这些办公室也在这栋楼的二楼。没错。所以你们走下楼梯去仓库，但多年后，他们在另一个地方的摄影棚里重建了整个办公室。那些楼梯依然存在，但它们通向虚无。那是一个大约三英尺宽的极小储物间，你得躲在那个小储物间里，然后按提示打开门走出来。所以有很多次，你要么独自待在那个小储物间里，要么和别人一起，比如有一次我和奥斯卡还有饰演凯文的布莱恩一起待在里面，那地方空间很小。
No. And we just tucked in that little closet for about 20 minutes until our characters came in the scene. But this was where we were really using this real warehouse and this real space. And there are some shots outside where you can tell that it's not the same place as seasons later. I know, I know. There's some things they couldn't cover.
没错。我们就在那个小储物间里挤了大约20分钟，直到我们的角色进入场景。但这是我们真正使用这个真实仓库和真实空间的地方。外面有一些镜头，你可以看出它和几季之后的地方不一样。我知道，我知道。有些东西他们没法遮挡。
That's fun for the super nerd. Okay, well, I think we should play this clip of Michael introducing Ryan to Craig Robinson, who plays Daryl, the manager of the warehouse. This is one of my favorite introductions of a character on The Office because ever the the sort of journey that his name takes with Michael of how Michael comes up with this nickname for him is so ridiculous. And Craig Robinson does such a great job in the scene of just throwing it away. He's so amazing. All right, we should watch it. We'll discuss. And here we have Mita Rajah's neighborhood. Come on over here. Hey, this is Ryan. He's
这对超级剧迷来说很有趣。好吧，我觉得我们应该播放这段迈克尔把瑞安介绍给饰演仓库经理达里尔的克雷格·罗宾逊的片段。这是《办公室》中我最喜欢的角色介绍之一，因为他的名字在迈克尔口中经历的那个过程，以及迈克尔想出这个绰号的方式实在太荒谬了。克雷格·罗宾逊在这一幕中表现得非常出色，那种漫不经心的感觉演得太棒了。好了，我们来看一下。看完再讨论。这里是米塔·拉贾的邻居。过来这边。嘿，这是瑞安。他正在
temping upstairs. And this is the foreman, Mita Rajah's. It's not my real name. No, it's Daryl. Daryl is Mitha Rajaz. Daryl Rogers. Daryl Philbin. Then Regis. Then Reg, then Roger. Then Mitha Rogers. What is the amazing history?
楼上做临时工。这是工头，米塔·拉贾。那不是我的真名。不，是达里尔。达里尔是米塔·拉贾。达里尔·罗杰斯。达里尔·菲尔宾。然后是里吉斯。然后是雷吉，然后是罗杰。然后是米塔·罗杰斯。这真是个神奇的历史。
How many years has Michael been calling him by not his name of Daryl? I know. It's so good. It's so good. And you so see in It's so good. And you so see in Michael's brain how he got there. Oh, makes total sense.
迈克尔叫错他的名字叫了多少年了？我知道。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。你完全能看出迈克尔的脑回路是怎么走到这一步的。哦，完全说得通。
Darryl Philbin. Philbin. Oh, Regis Philbin. Reg. Raj. Raj. Mr. Rajas. Mr. Rajas.
达里尔·菲尔宾。菲尔宾。哦，里吉斯·菲尔宾。雷吉。拉杰。拉杰先生。拉杰斯先生。
So ridiculous. It totally works. And I have to wonder, this is like when I would love to do a dial-in phone call, but to call Mike Schur, because Mike Schur was one of our writers on the show and he is married to J.J. Philbin. J.J. Philbin's dad is Regis. And I know Greg had told me that some of the people's names were formations of different people who had family and stuff on the show. Well you know Jim Halpert is Greg's friend, Jim Halpert. His name is yes. His name is, it's his first and last name and Greg asked him permission to use his name
太荒谬了。完全行得通。我不得不怀疑，这就像我本来想打个电话给迈克·舒尔，因为迈克·舒尔是我们剧组的编剧之一，他娶了J.J.菲尔宾。J.J.菲尔宾的父亲是里吉斯。我知道格雷格曾告诉我，剧中一些人的名字是根据剧组人员的家人等组合而成的。你知道吉姆·哈珀特就是格雷格的朋友，吉姆·哈珀特。他的名字是，是的。他的名字，就是他的名和姓，格雷格征求了他的许可才使用他的名字
and the guy was like, oh yeah, sure, it's no big deal. He came to set one day. He was like, yeah, it's no big deal. Nine years later, it was kind of a big deal. Yeah. When he would go all places and be like, it's Jim Helpert. And he'd be like, oh, yeah, okay. Yeah, right.
那个人当时说，哦，好的，没问题。他有一天来到片场。他说，是的，没问题。九年后，这成了一个大问题。是的。当他去任何地方，别人都会说，你是吉姆·哈珀特。他就会说，哦，是的，好吧。是的，没错。
I know, and Phyllis Lapin, Phyllis's last name Lapin, Lapin is the last name of a friend of Greg's as well. And so I have to think that Daryl Philbin was maybe Mike Schur's nod to his father-in-law, his wife's side of the family, but then became this great runner for Michael Scott, which is so great. It's so good. And I have to say, this is a funny thing, David Denman and I really hit it off. Yeah, you did. We are good friends in real life.
我知道，还有菲利斯·拉平，菲利斯的姓氏拉平，拉平也是格雷格一位朋友的姓氏。所以我不得不认为达里尔·菲尔宾可能是迈克·舒尔对他岳父，也就是他妻子那边的家人的致敬，但后来却成了迈克尔·斯科特的一个很棒的梗，这太棒了。太好了。我必须说，这很有趣，大卫·丹曼和我真的很投缘。是的，你们确实很投缘。我们在现实生活中是好朋友。
We especially hit it off in this episode. And it was weird because I think I had spent a lot of time talking to John Krasinski between scenes, and now I was talking to David Denman. And John was like, hey, where's my chat buddy? Where'd my friend go? So it was really weird. And yeah, David and I, we became couple friends.
我们在这一集中特别投缘。这很奇怪，因为我觉得我在场景之间花了很多时间跟约翰·卡拉辛斯基聊天，现在我却在跟大卫·丹曼聊天。约翰就说，嘿，我的聊天伙伴去哪了？我的朋友去哪了？所以这真的很奇怪。是的，大卫和我，我们成了情侣朋友。
He had a girlfriend at the time, and I was with someone at the time. And so we would all hang out and play poker together. But he became a really, really good friend of mine outside of the office. And I think it's probably a weird thing for people to imagine that one my, one of my best connections on the show was with David Dunman, my jerk boyfriend, Roy.
他当时有女朋友，我当时也有男朋友。所以我们经常一起出去玩，一起打扑克。但他成了我在《办公室》之外一个非常非常好的朋友。我想人们很难想象，我在剧中最好的联系之一竟然是和大卫·丹曼，也就是我那个混蛋男友罗伊。
Your jerk boyfriend. I'm sure right now if you guys went out for lunch and you and him walked in, people would be like, why are you with Roy? It's so true. Where's Jim? I know. I had lunch with Rainn Wilson and people lost their minds. We were like, oh my God, Dwayne Angela. All right, here we go. We're moving on, Jenna. We're moving on. What happens next? Well, they go back up in the office, right?
你那个混蛋男友。我敢肯定，如果现在你们一起去吃午饭，你和他走进去，人们会问，你为什么跟罗伊在一起？太真实了。吉姆呢？我知道。我和雷恩·威尔逊一起吃午饭，人们都疯了。我们就像，哦天哪，德怀特和安吉拉。好了，我们继续吧，珍娜。我们继续。接下来发生了什么？好吧，他们回到办公室了，对吧？
Yes. They go back to work. That's when he says, okay, who's starting? Stanley, of course. Yeah. And he's like, why of course? Yeah, Leslie David Baker's like, excuse me, like kind of look he gives him is so perfect.
是的。他们回去工作了。就在那时他说，好吧，谁先开始？当然是斯坦利。是的。他说，为什么是当然？是的，莱斯利·大卫·贝克那种“你说什么”的眼神太完美了。
Now, if I remember correctly, Leslie was truly a horrible basketball player. Yes, Leslie was like, oh, I don't play sports. Yeah. Not a sports guy. That was really perfect. And Phyllis was so excited. She wanted to be on the team in real life.
现在，如果我没记错的话，莱斯利确实是个糟糕的篮球运动员。是的，莱斯利当时说，哦，我不做运动。是的，不是运动型的人。那真的很完美。菲利斯当时非常兴奋。她在现实生活中想加入球队。
I'm talking Phyllis in real life. Was like so excited to be part of the basketball team. Phyllis in her youth was a burlesque dancer. This is true. And she has quite the moves. And there is a tiny clip as they warm up before the game where she's moving her arms and stuff, but her warmup seemed very like dance.
我说的是现实生活中的菲利斯。她对能成为篮球队的一员感到非常兴奋。菲利斯年轻时是个滑稽剧舞者。这是真的。她很有舞步。在比赛前的热身中有一个小片段，她挥动着手臂之类的，但她的热身看起来非常像舞蹈。
Burlesque? Yeah, dance-like. But she was, there's a few times throughout the game when she finally gets to participate and you see her smile and that's genuine. Like Phyllis was like, I'm in the game, I'm so excited. I do have to say before we get into the game part, one thing is that you see my character
滑稽剧？是的，像舞蹈一样。但在整个比赛过程中，有几次她终于有机会参与，你看到她的笑容，那是真诚的。就像菲利斯说，我在比赛中，我太兴奋了。我必须说，在我们进入比赛部分之前，有一件事是，你看到我的角色
looking through the supply kind of closet and I'm looking for the first aid kit. And so, and I'm like, where's the first aid kit? And then Dwight doesn't even look around, he just holds it up, right? And I have this line that to me is kind of like that Todd Packer line in the first part of the episode that is so loaded with information.
在翻找储物间，我在找急救箱。然后我说，急救箱在哪？德怀特甚至不用看周围，他直接把它举了起来，对吧？我有一句台词，对我来说就像这一集前半部分托德·帕克那句台词一样，充满了信息量。
Yes. Because I say, how many times do I have to tell you? I'm the safety officer, not you. Yes. It's like, how many times has Dwight tried to usurp Angela's power? How many times has he taken that first aid kit and tried to be safety officer?
是的。因为我说，我要告诉你多少次？我是安全官，不是你。是的。这就像，德怀特试图篡夺安吉拉的权力多少次了？他拿走那个急救箱并试图当安全官多少次了？
What is their backstory there? I would love to know. I love that we don't know. We just know that they are adversarial in this moment and that they both love power and control. Later in season two, in the episode email surveillance, we will learn that Dwight and Angela are in a relationship. So my question to you is, looking back, do you think they were already in a relationship. Yes. So my question to you is, looking back, do you think they were already in a relationship now?
他们的背景故事是什么？我真想知道。我喜欢我们不知道这一点。我们只知道他们此刻是对手，而且他们都热爱权力和控制。在第二季的《电子邮件监控》一集中，我们将了解到德怀特和安吉拉正在谈恋爱。所以我的问题是，回过头来看，你认为他们当时已经在谈恋爱了吗？是的。所以我的问题是，回过头来看，你认为他们当时已经在谈恋爱了吗？
Or do you think that this is maybe the beginning of that sexual tension? I don't think they're in a relationship yet. I think it's the beginning. I think it's the beginning. I think they both kind of, they like each other, but they also are annoyed by each other. So they have this weird yin, yin and yang pool.
还是你认为这可能只是那种性张力的开始？我不认为他们当时已经在谈恋爱了。我认为这是开始。我认为这是开始。我认为他们彼此都有点喜欢对方，但又对对方感到厌烦。所以他们有一种奇怪的阴阳吸引力。
And I think it's the beginning. I feel like the more they gave that bit to you guys to play, then it gave them the idea to write this as some weird, twisted romance. Yes. And when we found out we were a couple, was at the table read. And that happened a lot for us on this show, is that the writers would come up with things. And that happened a lot for us on this show,
我认为这是开始。我觉得他们给你们演的戏份越多，就越给了他们把这写成某种奇怪、扭曲的浪漫故事的灵感。是的。当我们发现我们是一对时，是在剧本围读会上。这在我们的剧集中经常发生，编剧们会想出一些点子。这在我们的剧集中经常发生，
is that the writers would come up with things and we would sit down at lunch all together around a table. Once a week. Once a week and read a new script, usually on Wednesday, we would read a new script and we would, they would be handing them to us as we walked in the room. Sometimes the paper was hot. Yes, I remember.
编剧们会想出一些点子，我们大家会围坐在桌子旁吃午饭。每周一次。每周一次，读一个新的剧本，通常是在周三，我们会读一个新的剧本，我们走进房间时他们会把剧本递给我们。有时纸还是热的。是的，我记得。
And we would cold read these out loud and a lot of times we discovered information as we read them. And that was definitely one of them when we see the Birkenstocks moving in the dollhouse in the backyard, we were like, oh my god. I remember I found out Pam was pregnant during a table read. And being like a fan of the show, I would want information like anyone else. Yeah. And I would get it early, but I would still have to wait for that table read moment to find out. Yeah.
我们会大声朗读这些剧本，很多时候我们是在阅读时才发现剧情的。这绝对是其中之一，当我们看到后院娃娃屋里的勃肯鞋在动时，我们都惊呆了。我记得我是在剧本围读会上发现帕姆怀孕的。作为剧迷，我会像其他人一样想要信息。是的。我会提前知道，但我仍然必须等到那个围读时刻才能确认。是的。
Like we weren't, they wouldn't say, OK, this season, here are the five things that are going to happen to your character. No. No, you had to wait for each week to see how the drama unfolded. Yeah, it was really fun. Oh, I have to tell the story.
就像我们不会被提前告知，好吧，这一季，你的角色会发生这五件事。不。不，你必须每周等待，看看剧情如何展开。是的，这真的很有趣。哦，我必须讲个故事。
So OK, so as Michael picks his team, we then see a montage of all of us throwing things into the trash can. It starts with Dwight, he tries to make a shot, he misses, I thought his face was so cute when he like did his fingers like, I missed it by this. So close. And he got to be on the team and he was so happy.
所以，当迈克尔挑选他的球队时，我们看到了一段我们所有人把东西扔进垃圾桶的蒙太奇。从德怀特开始，他尝试投篮，没投中，我觉得他那个表情太可爱了，他用手指比划着，我差了这么多。太接近了。他能进队，他太高兴了。
And then of course, Stanley misses, Oscar gets it in no problem, you know, and people go around making these baskets. Well, we did B-roll. We had always had A camera and we had B camera on the show. And the B camera would pick up all these little moments happening in the background. And so they had all of us toss things kind of nonchalantly into our our desk trash can. And I made mine on the first try. And I made like three in a row and
然后当然，斯坦利没投中，奥斯卡轻而易举地投进了，你知道，大家都在投篮。好吧，我们拍了B卷。我们剧组总是有A摄像机和B摄像机。B摄像机负责捕捉背景中发生的所有小瞬间。所以他们让我们所有人漫不经心地把东西扔进办公桌的垃圾桶里。我第一次就投中了。我连续投中了三个，
they didn't even include it because they're like it just doesn't track that you would that Angela would like be like a ringer or anything and of course Brian made his yeah and and that is something you guys should know is that where our trailers were our trailers are where you hang out between scenes right where our trailers were they put up a basketball hoop. And we would play horse in between scenes if we had a break, we would all go out there and play horse. And I have a photo of us.
他们甚至没剪进去，因为他们觉得安吉拉看起来像个高手这不符合逻辑，当然布莱恩投中了。是的，你们应该知道，我们的拖车停放的地方，就是我们在场景之间休息的地方，对吧？在我们的拖车那里，他们装了一个篮球架。如果休息的话，我们都会去那里玩投篮游戏。我有一张我们的照片。
And Brian was an amazing shooter. Brian's an amazing athlete. He's a great athlete. Great golfer. So the cast knew this. And so when this episode came about, we all knew what a great shooter he was. But the writers and Greg didn't know. They did not know.
布莱恩是个了不起的射手。布莱恩是个了不起的运动员。他是个伟大的运动员。伟大的高尔夫球手。所以演员们都知道这一点。所以当这一集出现时，我们都知道他是个多好的射手。但编剧和格雷格不知道。他们不知道。
And so in between scenes, he would grab a basketball and just start shooting. And he was just sinking them left and right. And it became a thing at the end of the episode. So you'll see him, they just let the camera roll. He makes one shot, gets it in from kind of close to the free point line. But then he keeps taking a step back, step back. So by the end, he's well at like three point range. And he made, I think it was 13 or 14 in a row. Yes. And they got it. We show three or four, I think. Yeah. But he actually made, I think it was
所以场景之间，他会抓起一个篮球就开始投。他投得左一个右一个。这成了这一集结尾的一个梗。所以你会看到，他们只是让摄像机一直开着。他投进了一个球，是从离三分线很近的地方投进的。但他不断往后退，往后退。所以到最后，他已经在三分线外了。我想他连续投进了13或14个。是的。他们拍到了。我想我们展示了三四个。是的。但他实际上投进了，我想是
14. And we all were there with pins and needles. And when he missed the 15th one, we all cheered. It was so cool. There's another moment in the basketball game that's coming to mind. There's a moment where Michael is supposed to, as a joke, it was in the script. He's supposed to throw the ball from really far.
14个。我们所有人都紧张地看着。当他没投中第15个时，我们都欢呼起来。太酷了。篮球比赛中还有另一个瞬间浮现在脑海中。有一个瞬间，迈克尔本应该开个玩笑，剧本里写的，他应该从很远的地方投球。
Right. And it doesn't go in. Yeah. And then he's supposed to be all upset, like, I usually make those or whatever. The first time, do you remember what happened the first time? Steve made it. He made it.
对。结果没进。是的。然后他应该表现得很沮丧，比如，我通常能投进之类的。第一次，你记得第一次发生了什么吗？史蒂夫投进了。他投进了。
He made the most ridiculous alley-oop from the other side of the warehouse and we all cheered. We cheered. And they were like, no, you guys can't cheer. He doesn't make that. And Steve, I'm sure Steve was like, oh man, I wish that could go in. I know that should be a deleted scene for sure.
他从仓库的另一端投出了最荒谬的空中接力，我们都欢呼了。我们欢呼了。他们说，不，你们不能欢呼。他投不进那个。史蒂夫，我敢肯定史蒂夫当时想，哦天哪，我真希望那个能进。我知道那绝对应该是个删减片段。
That was crazy. Okay. Oh, should we also talk about a little bit about the Jim Pam part of this episode? Yes. Yes. Because they have such an awkward flirty scene. That is so funny to me. First of all, I love that the subject of their flirt is the mall or wave runners.
那太疯狂了。好吧。哦，我们是不是也该聊聊这一集里吉姆和帕姆的部分？是的。是的。因为他们有一场尴尬的调情戏。这对我来说太搞笑了。首先，我喜欢他们调情的主题是商场或水上摩托。
This is so relatable to me because I have family that live in like Northern Texas and on the weekend you go to the lake and you go to the mall. Yes, exactly. These are the choices. Jim is going to go to the mall for the weekend if he doesn't have to work. The outlets, right? The outlets, the outlet malls. And then Pam said that if Roy wins, and they don't have to work on Saturday since that was the bet, if Roy wins, they're going to take the wave runners up to the lake. And Jim says, well, I think Roy is going to be working. So I think you're going to be coming to the mall with me, you know, just if you want to
这对我来说太有共鸣了，因为我有家人住在德克萨斯州北部，周末你会去湖边，你会去商场。是的，完全正确。这就是选择。如果吉姆不用工作，他周末会去商场。奥特莱斯，对吧？奥特莱斯，折扣商场。然后帕姆说，如果罗伊赢了，他们周六就不用工作，因为那是赌注，如果罗伊赢了，他们会带水上摩托去湖边。吉姆说，嗯，我觉得罗伊会去工作。所以我觉得你会跟我去商场，你知道，如果你想
save big on brand names. Super cute. But I have to say that whole wave runner backstory, that was based on a backstory that I wrote about Pam and Roy that ended up making it into the show in this very subtle way. So I remember trying to justify just as myself, why is Pam still engaged to Roy after three years? Because in this episode, you find out, they've been engaged for three years.
在名牌上省大钱的话。超级可爱。但我必须说，整个水上摩托的背景故事，是基于我写的一个关于帕姆和罗伊的背景故事，最终以这种非常微妙的方式进入了剧中。所以我记得我试图为自己辩解，为什么帕姆在三年后还和罗伊订婚？因为在这一集中，你发现，他们已经订婚三年了。
Her little toaster oven is broken. Her toaster oven, she's sad. It's a reminder. She got her engagement party is broken. They're still not married. So I asked myself, why? Why are they not married yet? It's been three years.
她的小烤箱坏了。她的小烤箱，她很难过。这是一个提醒。她订婚派对收到的礼物坏了。他们还没结婚。所以我问自己，为什么？为什么他们还没结婚？已经三年了。
What is the reason? So in my head, I came up with the reason that they had been saving money for the wedding. Wait, wait, wait, wait. I have to pause. Yes. I love this about Jenna so much, you guys. This is her actor prep.
原因是什么？所以在我的脑海里，我想出了一个原因，他们一直在为婚礼存钱。等等，等等，等等。我必须暂停。是的。我太喜欢珍娜这一点了，你们大家。这是她的演员准备工作。
This is my actor prep. She did this solely for herself. No one asked me to do it. No one asked her to do it. I wrote it in essay form. Again, Jenna, first of her name, keeper of the notes. I would love to find this document. It was my PAM document. Oh my God. And I have all these little things I made up. Oh my God. You love to find this document. It was my Pam document. Oh my God. All these little things
这是我的演员准备工作。她完全是为自己做的。没人让我这么做。没人让她这么做。我以论文的形式写了下来。再说一次，珍娜，名字的首位，笔记的守护者。我真想找到这份文档。那是我的帕姆文档。哦天哪。我编造了所有这些小细节。哦天哪。你喜欢找到这份文档。那是我的帕姆文档。哦天哪。所有这些小细节
I made up. Oh my God. You have to find it. Okay. So go. So what was your backstory for yourself? My backstory was that they had been saving money for the wedding and about a year into their engagement without telling Pam Roy spent the money on a pair of wave runners with his brother. This is perfect, Jenna. Yeah. This is perfect. And he, you know, soners with his brother. This is perfect, Jenna. This is perfect. So he and his brother bought these pair of Waverunners with their wedding money. But Roy was like, we're going to have so much fun with these. So it broke Pam's heart.
我编造的。哦天哪。你一定要找到它。好吧。所以继续。那么你为自己设定的背景故事是什么？我的背景故事是，他们一直在为婚礼存钱，在订婚大约一年后，罗伊没告诉帕姆，就把钱和他的兄弟买了一对水上摩托。这太完美了，珍娜。是的。这太完美了。他和他的兄弟用他们的婚礼钱买了这对水上摩托。但罗伊说，我们会玩得很开心的。这伤透了帕姆的心。
What an ass. These Waverunners. Yeah. And I told Greg this story, just bantering with him. And he was like, oh my gosh, I love that. We got to put that in. We got to put that in the Waverunners. We got to put that in the Waverunners., oh my gosh, I love that. We gotta put that in. We gotta put that in the Waverunners. Yeah.
真是个混蛋。这些水上摩托。是的。我把这个故事告诉了格雷格，只是跟他闲聊。他说，哦天哪，我喜欢这个。我们得把它放进去，我们得把它放进去，水上摩托。我们得把它放进去，水上摩托。哦天哪，我喜欢这个。我们得把它放进去，我们得把它放进去，水上摩托。是的。
We gotta put that in the Waverunners. That is so good. I love that. I feel like as I talk to some of our cast members about our time on the show, we all had moments where we gave ourselves a little backstory like that. And obviously we won't get into it here.
我们得把它放进去，水上摩托。这太好了。我喜欢这个。我觉得当我跟我们的一些演员聊起我们在剧组的时光时，我们都有过给自己设定这样一个小背景故事的时刻。显然我们不会在这里深入讨论。
Mine was sprinkles. You invented sprinkles. I did, but that's pilot. That's pilot's talk. But I did not know you did that about the Waverunners. And that is absolutely what Roy would have done. He would have been like, listen, that money, we were going to spend on the wedding,
我的是斯普林克尔斯。你发明了斯普林克尔斯。我确实发明了，但那是试播集的事。那是试播集的话题。但我不知道你关于水上摩托的事。那绝对是罗伊会做的事。他会说，听着，那笔钱，我们本来要花在婚礼上的，
I got a really good deal on Waverunners. Yeah, he surprised her with some Waverunners. Oh my God, that's amazing. What Pam's always wanted. I feel like we should say from a production standpoint, we spent two days down in the warehouse playing basketball. That's right. And there was a lot of the guys just playing basketball
我买水上摩托买到了个好价钱。是的，他用一些水上摩托给了她惊喜。哦天哪，太神奇了。帕姆一直想要的。我觉得我们应该从制作的角度说一下，我们在仓库里花了整整两天时间打篮球。没错。有很多家伙只是在打篮球，
and they filmed them to get like random shots. But then there were all of these scripted moments that they had to get. Right, to make the game make sense. Yes, yes. Exactly. Can we speak about some highlights from the basketball game? Let's do it, let's do it. Rain's crazy nose guard.
他们拍摄他们以获得随机镜头。但后来他们必须拍摄所有这些有剧本的时刻。对，为了让比赛合理。是的，是的。完全正确。我们能聊聊篮球比赛中的一些亮点吗？来吧，来吧。雷恩那个疯狂的护鼻器。
Oh my God, you know, I knew a guy in high school, Ken. He had to wear one. And they're special. I guess this was Greg's idea. He wanted him to wear this nose guard. But you know what I love? We never mention it. Nope.
哦天哪，你知道，我在高中认识一个叫肯的家伙。他必须戴一个。它们很特别。我想这是格雷格的主意。他想让他戴这个护鼻器。但你知道我喜欢什么吗？我们从来没提过它。不。
We don't know why he's wearing it. Nope. Was he injured once, or is he just afraid of injury? We don't know. We don't know. But of course, he would wear it. When Rain takes his shirt off to be skins. By the way, Rain, I think loves taking his shirt off.
我们不知道他为什么要戴它。不。他受过伤吗，还是他只是害怕受伤？我们不知道。我们不知道。但当然，他会戴着它。当雷恩脱掉衬衫赤膊上阵时。顺便说一句，雷恩，我觉得他喜欢脱掉衬衫。
He loves the shock value of his white pasty body. And he liked to stick his belly out and like pat it, like look at it. Can we also just for a minute, none of us knew what it was gonna look like when Stanley dribbled the basketball. It was in the script that he is not good at dribbling. That's all.
他喜欢他那苍白皮肤带来的冲击感。他喜欢把肚子挺出来，拍拍它，看着它。我们能顺便聊聊吗，我们谁都不知道斯坦利运球时会是什么样子。剧本里写着他不擅长运球。就这样。
That's all. And that Michael would look and just have this moment of like, ah, crap. Are you kidding me? And that dribble that Leslie David Baker did. With his hand behind him. Ridiculous. Ridiculous.
就这样。迈克尔会看一眼，然后露出那种“啊，该死”的表情。你在开玩笑吗？莱斯利·大卫·贝克做的那个运球。手放在背后。荒谬。荒谬。
It was so perfect. It was literal perfection. Yeah. Oh, oh, you have to tell Jim, you have to tell about when John actually got hurt. Yes. We actually had a real injury and they just kept the camera rolling.
太完美了。简直是字面意义上的完美。是的。哦，哦，你必须告诉吉姆，你必须说说约翰真的受伤的时候。是的。我们确实发生了一次真实的受伤，他们只是让摄像机一直开着。
They did, this was not scripted. The part where Roy knocks Jim in the nose and his nose is bleeding. That was just David Denman blocking, like getting a ball and blocking out. There was some real basketball competition when they were playing. So the dudes got a little testosterone. They got a little duty.
他们确实拍了，这不是剧本安排的。罗伊撞到吉姆鼻子的部分，他的鼻子在流血。那只是大卫·丹曼在防守，抢球并封盖。他们打球时确实有真正的篮球竞争。所以这些家伙有点雄性激素。他们有点冲动。
Yeah, they got a little duty. But he did. He threw his elbow back, not knowing that John was there and clocked John. And his nose started gushing blood. I think that sound you hear is his nose. I asked Dave Rogers. Our editor. Yes, because I remember the debate when they were editing this episode.
是的，他们有点冲动。但他确实做到了。他向后挥肘，不知道约翰在那里，直接击中了约翰。他的鼻子开始喷血。我想你听到的那个声音就是他的鼻子。我问过戴夫·罗杰斯。我们的剪辑师。是的，因为我记得他们在剪辑这一集时的争论。
Well, we heard it in real time. You can hear it in real life. We were like, dang. Yes, we knew, we were like, is his nose broken? Yeah. And we had to pause and like ice pack him. First of all, they didn't stop rolling. They kept documenting it.
好吧，我们实时听到了。你在现实生活中能听到。我们当时想，该死。是的，我们知道，我们想，他的鼻子断了吗？是的。我们不得不暂停，给他冰敷。首先，他们没有停止拍摄。他们一直在记录。
They kept documenting it. And so we see that John is, John ran off cause he was in pain and his nose starts bleeding. And I didn't know what to do. So I picked up that fricking first aid kit and I walked over to him and then I was like, wait, what am I doing? There's nothing in to do. So I picked up that fricking first aid kit and I walked over to him and then I was like, wait, what am I doing? There's nothing in that kit.
他们一直在记录。所以我们看到约翰，约翰跑开了，因为他很痛，他的鼻子开始流血。我不知道该怎么办。所以我拿起了那个该死的急救箱，我走到他身边，然后我想，等等，我在做什么？那个箱子里什么都没有。所以我拿起了那个该死的急救箱，我走到他身边，然后我想，等等，我在做什么？那个箱子里什么都没有。
It's like empty. Was that sound really? Apparently the live audio was not strong enough to use. So they pumped it up. They added a popping sound so that it would more sound like what we heard in real life. Cause I did ask Dave, because I remember. I was worried John broke his nose. We all were. Yeah. We all were. And then they also told me at a certain point,
就像是空的。那个声音是真的吗？显然现场音频不够强，无法使用。所以他们调大了。他们加了一个爆裂声，这样听起来更像我们在现实生活中听到的声音。因为我确实问过戴夫，因为我记得。我担心约翰断了鼻子。我们都担心。是的。我们都担心。然后他们还在某个时候告诉我，
they had to stop it where they stopped it because blood was dripping on the floor. And it looked a little gruesome. Yeah. They had actually a few injuries. I remember Leslie got hurt. And then who else? There was someone else.
他们不得不停下来，因为血滴在了地板上。看起来有点恐怖。是的。他们实际上受了几次伤。我记得莱斯利受伤了。还有谁？还有别人。
Did someone else get hurt? I feel like a few guys got some bumps. Anyway, the guys gave it their all on the court. They really went for it. Also, we have to talk about Michael's free throw moment. Oh my God. That made me laugh so hard. That is an example of Steve Carell's impeccable comedic timing.
还有别人受伤吗？我觉得几个家伙都受了点轻伤。总之，这些家伙在球场上全力以赴。他们真的拼了。另外，我们必须谈谈迈克尔的罚球时刻。哦天哪。那让我笑得太厉害了。那是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔无可挑剔的喜剧时机的例子。
He does not rush. He makes you wait for it. You know when he's setting up this ridiculous free throw that it's not going to go in. We all know it's not going to go in. And yet somehow he makes us wait so long that it's even funnier. And he just throws it completely over. He throws it over the whole hoop. And it's great too, because you know someone has to run and get that ball. You don't see it happen, but you know that moment
他不着急。他让你等待。你知道当他准备这个荒谬的罚球时，它不会进。我们都知道它不会进。然而不知何故，他让我们等了那么久，以至于它变得更搞笑了。他直接把它投得完全偏离了篮筐。他把它投过了整个篮筐。这也很棒，因为你知道有人得跑去捡那个球。你没看到它发生，但你知道那个时刻
when you're playing basketball. Yeah, we didn't even talk about his ridiculous warm up stretches before the game, where he made his arms like noodles. And then there's little moments within the game where you see he just wants so desperately to be like, have a friend and to be cool. Like when Darryl and Lon be cool. Like when, when, um, Darryl and Lonnie do their like high fives and he's just watching it so like giddy, like, Oh,
当你打篮球时。是的，我们甚至没谈到他在比赛前那些荒谬的热身拉伸，他把手臂弄得像面条一样。然后在比赛中有一些小瞬间，你看到他只是非常渴望像，有一个朋友，并且很酷。就像当达里尔和朗尼击掌时，他只是看着，非常兴奋，就像，哦，
that's cool. Yes. And then Dwight wants to do that with him, but he rejects Dwight. Dwight will be Michael's friend that Michael's always wanted, but Michael's like, you're not good enough. Not cool enough. No, he wants to do it with like Jim. He wants to have a high five with Jim who he's decided is the coolest in the office. I know. Or Ryan. Or Todd Packer.
那很酷。是的。然后德怀特想和他那样做，但他拒绝了德怀特。德怀特会是迈克尔一直想要的那个朋友，但迈克尔却说，你不够好。不够酷。不，他想和吉姆那样做。他想和吉姆击掌，他认为吉姆是办公室里最酷的。我知道。或者瑞安。或者托德·帕克。
Or Todd Packer. Anyone but Dwight, basically. Anyone but Dwight. So the basketball episode, I think has some of like the best quotes of the whole first season. So many good ones. So many good ones. You have one of the best ones that really
或者托德·帕克。基本上除了德怀特以外的任何人。除了德怀特。所以篮球这一集，我觉得有一些第一季最好的台词。太多好的了。太多好的了。你有一句最好的，真的
I've seen on t-shirts and coffee mugs. So, go. I used to sign headshots with this line when people would ask me for my autograph. Do it. Please don't throw garbage at me. I love it. I feel like it sums up Pam's entire relationship
我在T恤和咖啡杯上看到过。所以，说吧。当人们找我要签名时，我过去常签这句台词。说吧。请不要往我身上扔垃圾。我喜欢它。我觉得它总结了帕姆和迈克尔的整个关系。
with Michael. The fact that she has to say the words, please don't throw garbage at me to her boss, just it says it all. It says it all. And also, you know, it's not the first time she said it. No, no. Or something like it. That's right. Yeah. And he throws that at your head and goes, off the backboard.
她不得不对她的老板说“请不要往我身上扔垃圾”这句话，这说明了一切。这说明了一切。而且，你知道，这不是她第一次这么说了。不，不。或者类似的话。没错。是的。他把那个扔到你头上，然后说，打板得分。
Yeah. So ridiculous. Just please don't throw garbage at me, Michael. Everything she's had to endure is all in that one line. Yeah. She's been working there for probably three, four years now. Yeah. Three or four years of garbage thrown at her head. In a relationship that's going nowhere.
是的。太荒谬了。请不要往我身上扔垃圾，迈克尔。她不得不忍受的一切都在那一句台词里。是的。她可能已经在那里工作了三四年了。是的。三四年的垃圾扔在她头上。在一段毫无进展的关系中。
Gosh, it's so sad. Poor Pam. ["The Last Supper"] All right. I don't know. What else can we talk about about basketball, you guys? You got to send in some of your questions for sure. I do love that this episode ended, of course, with Kevin syncing all of those shots. It was like so great. And yet nothing in the office is resolved. And are they all going to have to work Saturday? He says no one has to come in. Oh, that's right. That's right. That's right. He says
天哪，太悲伤了。可怜的帕姆。["最后的晚餐"] 好吧。我不知道。关于篮球我们还能聊些什么？你们一定要发来你们的问题。我确实喜欢这一集最后，当然，凯文投进了所有那些球。那太棒了。然而办公室里什么问题都没解决。他们都要在周六工作吗？他说没人必须来。哦，没错。没错。没错。他说
he's like, like, we're going to be downsized if we skip one Saturday. Exactly. But he's like, wait, what? So you do end on this sense of like, nothing, nothing's okay. Nothing's okay. Nothing's okay. Nothing's really different. And nothing is different. Nothing has been solved. Okay, so that was basketball. That's the basketball episode. That's the basketball episode. Yeah. Hopefully it wasn't a hot mess and you had a good time.
他说，如果我们错过一个周六，我们就会被裁员。完全正确。但他却说，等等，什么？所以你最终得到了一种感觉，就是，什么都没有，什么都不好。什么都不好。什么都没变。什么都没解决。好吧，这就是篮球。这就是篮球那一集。这就是篮球那一集。是的。希望它不是一团糟，你们玩得开心。
I had a good time. I had a good time. I loved watching it again. I have loved watching the show again in general. People come up to us all the time, especially now that the show has been out on Netflix and there's a whole new generation of fans. People really wig out. After so many years, it can become a little bit like I think I had lost some perspective on how good the show was. I knew it was good, but I hadn't watched it in years. I'm not sitting down watching myself on television.
我玩得很开心。我玩得很开心。我喜欢再次观看它。我喜欢再次观看这部剧。人们总是来找我们，尤其是现在这部剧在Netflix上播出，有了一整代新粉丝。人们真的疯了。这么多年后，我觉得我可能失去了一些对这部剧有多好的视角。我知道它很好，但我已经好几年没看了。我不会坐下来在电视上看自己。
So because of this podcast, I was forced to sit down and watch these episodes. And now when people come up to me and tell me the show is good, I'm like, I know, oh my gosh, it's so good, right? I mean, can you even believe it? Can you believe I was on it? That was me, I was on it. That was cool.
所以因为这个播客，我被迫坐下来观看这些剧集。现在当人们来找我告诉我这部剧很好时，我会说，我知道，哦天哪，它太好了，对吧？我是说，你敢相信吗？你敢相信我参演了它？那是我，我参演了它。那太酷了。
That's so cool. It's amazing, let's chat about it. Yeah, yeah, no, absolutely. And I get why it's comfort for people. You know, I really do. You can put it on in the background, and it's there. And we've talked about this before, but Dwight's always going to be Dwight,
太酷了。太神奇了，我们聊聊吧。是的，是的，不，绝对的。我明白为什么它对人们来说是一种慰藉。你知道，我真的明白。你可以把它放在背景里播放，它就在那里。我们之前谈过这个，但德怀特永远是德怀特，
and accounting is accounting. And you've got Pam and Jim there. And they become your little family in the background as you wind down from your day. I'm so thrilled that the show still keeps finding an audience. It's just so wonderful for me and for you and everyone involved. But I have a tiny gripe.
会计部就是会计部。你有帕姆和吉姆在那里。当你结束一天的工作时，他们成了你在背景里的小家庭。我很高兴这部剧仍然能找到观众。这对我，对你，对所有参与的人来说都太棒了。但我有一个小小的抱怨。
What? After rewatching this show. What? Do you know that not a single actor on our television show ever won an Emmy for their performance on the office. Oh, we're going there. Including Steve Carell. Wait, I was trying to wrap it up. I was trying to wrap it up with a bow.
什么？在重温这部剧之后。什么？你知道我们电视节目中没有一个演员因为在《办公室》中的表演而获得过艾美奖吗？哦，我们要谈这个了。包括史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。等等，我本来想把它总结一下。我本来想把它总结得圆满一点。
No, I have a gripe. Jenna's like, wait, let me bitch for one second. I'm ending with a gripe. Oh, god, here we go. I think it is an absolute crime that Steve Carell was never awarded the top prize in his industry for the role of Michael Scott. For the role of Michael Scott.
不，我有一个抱怨。珍娜就像，等等，让我抱怨一秒钟。我以一个抱怨结束。哦，天哪，开始了。我认为史蒂夫·卡瑞尔因为迈克尔·斯科特这个角色而从未获得过他行业内的最高奖项，这绝对是一种犯罪。因为迈克尔·斯科特这个角色。
I agree. Because I kind of dare you to name another comedic male performance sort of as revolutionary and heartbreaking and funny and real. Yes. As his performance on that show. No, it was brilliant. He won the Golden Globe.
我同意。因为我敢让你说出另一个男性喜剧表演，像他在这部剧中的表演那样具有革命性、令人心碎、有趣且真实。是的。不，这太精彩了。他赢得了金球奖。
The show won Best Comedy Ensemble. We won an Emmy. We won some SAG awards. But Steve never won an Emmy. And the final year, he was nominated because his character was ending. His time in the office was ending. It was his final nomination. They had, it was me, you and John Krasinski in a row on the aisle and Steve I think was right in front of us or he was down a row and they had a camera on us as they announced the nominees
这部剧赢得了最佳喜剧群戏。我们赢得了艾美奖。我们赢得了一些演员工会奖。但史蒂夫从未赢得过艾美奖。最后一年，他被提名了，因为他的角色要结束了。他在办公室的时间要结束了。这是他最后的提名。他们有，是你，我和约翰·卡拉辛斯基坐在过道的一排，史蒂夫我想就在我们前面，或者他在后面一排，当他们宣布提名者时，摄像机对着我们
and then they announced the winner and the camera was right on us and when they didn't say Steve's name, I said, Mother Effer, out loud. And I am not, I don't curse guys, I'm not a big cursor. And it just flew out of my mouth because I couldn't believe it. And then I was instantly horrified because I thought, oh no, was I just on national television saying Mother Effer?
然后他们宣布了获胜者，摄像机直接对着我们，当他们没说史蒂夫的名字时，我大声说，他妈的。而且我不是，我不骂人，伙计们，我不是一个经常骂人的人。它直接从我嘴里飞了出来，因为我不敢相信。然后我立刻感到惊恐，因为我想，哦不，我刚才是不是在全国电视上说了他妈的？
I'm about to get a call from my mom, I know it. And her ladies in her Bible study are gonna to be like, Angela said mother effer. But they cut away very fast. So I don't think you saw it. But that's how we felt. We couldn't believe it. We couldn't believe it. Because his work in this show is brilliant.
我快要接到我妈妈的电话了，我知道。她圣经学习班的女士们会说，安吉拉说了他妈的。但他们切得非常快。所以我认为你没看到。但这就是我们的感受。我们不敢相信。我们不敢相信。因为他在这个剧里的工作太精彩了。
And our cast and our writers and everyone, they just did such an amazing job. There you go. Not ending with a nice bow, but there you go. There you go. All right with a nice bow, but there you go. There you go. All right. The end. The end. Thanks for tuning in and we're gonna keep watching
我们的演员、编剧和每个人，他们真的做得太棒了。给你。没有以一个圆满的结局结束，但给你。给你。好吧。结束。结束。感谢收听，我们将继续观看
episodes of The Office and we hope you join us for the re-watch and send in your questions. We'd love to go over to the mailbag slash special sauce. Yeah, next week is Hot Girl. Hot Girl. Amy Adams. Amy Adams. Yeah.
《办公室》的剧集，我们希望你加入我们的重温，并发送你的问题。我们很乐意去看看邮件袋/特别酱料。是的，下周是《辣妹》。《辣妹》。艾米·亚当斯。艾米·亚当斯。是的。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Wise-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber
感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。这一集最初是与Earwulf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·怀斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。
Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。